direction l'espagne à présent pays
européen affichant le taux de
contamination aux convives 19 le plus
élevé d'europe depuis hier soir 22h
madrid a été placé en quarantaine un
décret étend à l'ensemble de la capitale
les restrictions de circulation en
vigueur depuis une semaine dans certains
quartiers des mesures valables pour 2
semaines et qui pourront être renouvelés
les précisions de l'esc lisanga madrid
et placé en quarantaine
il est interdit d'entrer et de sortir de
la capitale espagnole sauf pour cas de
force majeure c'est à dire pour se
rendre à un rendez vous médical
s'occuper de personnes âgées mineurs ou
à charge mais aussi pour se rendre à la
banque ou au tribunal alors au total ce
sont 5 millions de personnes qui sont
confinés dans dix communes de la région
de madrid dans la capitale les magasins
devront fermer leurs portes à 22h et
leur capacité d'accueil est réduite de
50% les bars et restaurants devons aussi
faire mais plutôt à 23h et ils pourront
utiliser seulement 60% de leur terrasse
alors toutefois les habitants ont le
droit de se déplacer d'un quartier à un
autre
toutes ces mesures ont pour objectif de
freiner la propagation du coït 19 car
madrid concentre 35% des nouvelles
contaminations d'espagne et il ya déjà
40 % de sa capacité hospitalière qui est
dédié aux patients qu'aux vide alors
toutefois cette décision ne satisfait
pas le secteur médical
il estime que les autorités ont mis trop
de temps à réagir et que ces mesures ne
seront pas suffisantes et de son côté le
secteur économique d
c'est un manque à gagner de plus d'un
milliard d'euros par semaine et
d'ailleurs la région pouvait déposer un
recours contre ces mesures du
gouvernement espagnol